[Music]
you have the best microphone I've ever
seen any recording artist use he walks
out can I show them right now
this is his microphone look at this
microphone then look at my microphone
which one of us is in real show business
and which one of us is an idiot this is
fantastic where did you get this idea
years ago when I was performing I wanted
something that was you know that the
people could see from far to know it was
me so I decided to design something with
my name on it today do you ever think I
should go bigger
I should go bigger with this really get
my name out there now coz you can see it
from you know the people up top to see
you can see that right
it's fantastic you know I want to ask
you something so much to talk about
you're playing reggae music now
performing reggae music and there's part
of you I have heard that believes this
could get you into the White House
you've never performed for the President
and you think maybe that's because your
music in the past hasn't been
appropriate yeah for the present you
think that's true first of all most
definitely because I have music now that
speaks to the world right now as far as
what's going on so I definitely got
music that should be played you know
what in the White House okay so you
think this music maybe will get you an
invite in the past have you ever thought
of their any of your songs you've done
in the past we thought I can play that
for the president
hmm no no like drop it like it's hot
nothing like that not gonna work no
Snoop lion is the new name you came up
with Vista okay and when I first heard
the name I thought that's fierce you
know sounds and then I saw this picture
from a video you just did and I didn't
think it was so scary that is not a lion
that I'm not afraid of right there I
don't fear that lion I did that for the
kids now you know I love the kids so I
shot a video with a Eli Roth you want a
bunch of kids so the kids could have fun
with me as well sure okay that's a good
idea so that was for the kids that makes
sense right but in your mind you're a
more fear you're more fearsome line yeah
rely on what rely on you've had many
commercial endeavors we've talked about
them in the past help me out here your
car that you sold for is called a snoop
Deville snoop deville your barbecue is a
smoke degree
your online stores are called
snooper-market and the frankfurters you
sell our dog yeah okay so would you
basically I get the idea you would just
sit around think about your name and
then think mushrooms snoop dream of my
super scooper superscooper Snooper glue
yeah we get a piece of all of this
y'all came up with two ideas and I'm
running would you have over ten million
Twitter followers but you were slow to
embrace Twitter is that right you you
don't respect it because I didn't
understand what it was everybody would
say I'm following you I'm falling like
were you following me - I got a hold of
a suit that sounds paranoid why would
you be paranoid
[Music]
I am bracing now so I'm just kind of
like loving it you like it now and
you're also sending out some pretty
provocative twit pics
oh you follow me look at this this is
you in a bubble bath I was trying to get
a bubble bath ad deal dude at the time
you're trying to get a bubble bath deal
done yeah I wanted to get then you
realize no snoop thing rhymes with
bubble you can have the cure for a
terrible disease but if it didn't rhyme
with Snoop you destroy it
this saves lives nope doesn't rhyme with
Snoop so the so you you went from being
paranoid - everyone look at me in the
bathtub yeah I mean that was I was in
Dubai I was feeling real good about
myself that day when do you not feel
good about yourself
[Applause]